before I get into this video there's
something that I'd like to tell you all
about my good friend Joey tweeted a
while ago that he would try to ride
Condor and wallaby Holland as many times
as the amount of retweets he would get
on his three and he didn't expect much
of it at the time but many people ended
up retweeting it and it even featured on
national news radio and he ended up
garnering about 400 retweets now he's
actually gonna try and get as close as
possible to that number and to do that
he's gonna spend 20 hours in total on
Condor the 20th and 21st of July in
collaboration with wanna be themselves
now he's not doing this for nothing he's
trying to raise money for sniffing up
kicker which is a Dutch charity that
helps sick children and their families
by organizing events for them to forget
about the terrible circumstances that
they're in so if you want to support the
charity and if you want to support Joey
in his ridiculous journey to ride a
intensely painful of a coma slc coaster
then you can find the link in the
description of this video to Joey's
donation page as well as to the website
of stiffening up kicker and yeah let's
make sure that Joey's suffering isn't
all in vain that's all for now I might
come back to this in future videos but
for now let's get back to Jaeger on
all right it's the year 3019 humanity is
extracted all of the resources on earth
and is now wiped out and I just came
into existence as an artificial
intelligence based on existing silver
add videos that were still left over and
yeah it's been about a thousand years
since the last Jaeger own episode so
let's bring out a new one I'm just
kidding of course but yeah I know it's
been a while today I'm gonna work on a
flat right which yeah that's that's
basically all I'm gonna do in this
episode but I also think it'll be a bit
more interesting than it sounds like for
one this is going to be the first flat
right in the park and yeah this is
hopefully going to help and bring this
whole area together because the idea for
Jaeger horn has always been to make one
themed land of a park if you will rather
than a coaster and focus on the coaster
alone so it more or less came out of my
frustration with whenever I tried
building an actual park which I never
finished any enroller coast I can three
I never finished fantasy valley because
these things just go into crazy
proportions and with the level of detail
that I normally get into it's nearly
impossible to make a full fledged park
both in terms of how much time I have to
spend on it and how much the game starts
breaking down as soon as I get a few
themed blends in so yeah Jaeger horn is
really meant to be one themed area in a
Disney park or something like that
I threw most of my inspiration from big
grizzly Runaway Mine Train yeah it's a
complicated name but it's it's a really
cool mind train in Hong Kong's
Disneyland which actually used to be my
favorite coaster in the world that I
hadn't been on yet when I was afraid of
roller coasters it's a really really
weird story but you know up until I was
like 19 or 20 I never dared to ride any
coaster at all but I was always really
fascinated with scenery and that's
really how I got into these games and I
got over my fear of roller coasters
obviously just because of bland it goes
through but yeah that little backstory
aside I was really interested in the
scenery and especially
in big Risley Runaway Mine Train because
it has really cool scenery and unlike
the more traditional my train coasters
of Disney if you will like Big Thunder
Mountain or maybe even more recently the
Seven Dwarfs Mine Train it actually has
some really interesting elements and has
launches and backward sections and it's
mostly on the same elevation as well it
doesn't really have a mountain in the
same sense that Big Thunder Mountain has
one so altogether I thought it was a
really interesting and inspiring coaster
with a really cool themed area around it
with a lot of interaction with the paths
as well which is something that you
don't really have on Big Thunder
Mountain as well because it kind of sits
on its own Island some of them literally
do so yeah
altogether that's why this was a big
inspiration for Jaeger horn and why I
want to make Jaeger horn very much a
themed area with a lot of interaction
between the coaster and the paths and
also the surrounding scenery and that's
why I'm also getting into all of these
main street like sections on the outer
perimeter of the park and in this
episode into this flat right now it's
kind of interesting is as you might have
noticed at the start of this video I had
a circle mapped out with terrain paints
which was more or less to find a flat
ride which fit the size that I wanted
for this most because I wasn't really
looking for a particular kind of flat
ride I was mostly looking for a flat
ride which would fit underneath a roof
of a certain shape and size that I
wanted to go for because to be honest I
think for this flat ride the way that it
looks from the rest of the park as part
of the scenery is more important than
the actual flat ride itself so hence why
I'm also really focusing on the scenery
of this flat ride rather than the ride
itself and hence why I ended up settling
with this quite a vintage flat ride
which just spins around but it's I think
it's in the vintage back I'm not
entirely sure I always forget which
rides are in which packs but it's
definitely one of those classic rides
and I think it actually fits the Alpine
theme very well so that's really nice
and then for the the cover for the roof
or the
right skin as some people would like to
call it although this isn't quite a skin
because I'm not doing too much to the
design of the flat right itself
I'm building a gazebo like roof I was
thinking for a long time to build a much
more standard flat right cover which is
usually some kind of tents like roof
something very simple not very decorated
and when it comes to alpine themes
there's a lot of log supports and things
like that and I thought something like
that would fit into the park quite well
but when I was messing around with it it
just didn't have the same Swiss Chalet
our Nouveau kind of turn of the 20th
century looked to me as a lot of the
other buildings in the park do which are
very detailed and have a lot of those
elements in it so I ended up settling
for something which is a little bit more
out there and maybe a little bit too
detailed and ambitious for a simple flat
ride cover just to keep it out of the
rain but I think it just fits very well
into the scenery of the surrounding park
it also really does look like an
upscaled gazebo which is basically what
I took the design from you have a lot of
gazebos which have this large kind of
gentle sloped hexagonal structure to
them and then a slightly smaller
hexagonal roof on top of that with some
decoration between it and I basically
took that design and scaled it up to fit
over this flat ride but I'm also adding
a spire because at the end of the day
I'm still me and I still want to put
spires on everything but honestly I
think a spire on the minim of this flat
right cover will look really nice but
you'll see that later for now I'm still
working on the details of the roofs that
I put in place so far you might also
notice that the roofs are a bit
different from the roofs and the rest of
the park most of the roofs are wooden
shingles that I used all of the wooden
bracket pieces for which is also the
biggest contributor to the piece gowns
in this park and it's quite a bit of lag
but for this roof I wanted to try
something different so I'm going for
more a slated metal roof which is
something that you'll see in some alpine
areas at least
as far as my experience goes skiing in
Austria you see a lot of these metal
roofs on a lot of buildings and I'm not
entirely sure as to what the reasoning
behind this is could have to do with
snowfall because roofs in alpine areas
do really need to keep in mind that a
meter of snow on the roof as light as
snow might be really adds a lot of
weight and you have to be able to handle
that somehow but it could be for
different reasons as well for some
reason when I went to Tallinn recently
I've noticed that the old town in Saline
has a lot of metal roofs as well but I
think in this case is very much a result
of renovations on a lot of these
buildings because the old town was
somewhat neglected during the USSR
period and these metal roofs are
probably quite a bit cheaper to install
than for tile roofs but honestly I'm not
entirely sure about that feel free to
educate me on my ignorance in the
comments section regardless of what I
thought about this I thought that the
the metal look looks a little bit better
for this flat right cover so really
that's the only reason why I ended up
going for it it's a bit nicer looking I
think for this kind of structure as well
than shingles or especially tiles which
you wouldn't really see often on a
gazebo either so yeah that's why I'm
going for this and yeah here's the this
fire as always it's it's quite fun to
just make these small parts of round
structures and copy them around which
honestly for me makes building domes and
round spires and really anything that's
round and that you can use this this
copying trick with and one of the one of
the most fun things to build because you
can just build one small area and go
crazy on the details and try to perfect
it and then all you have to do is copy
it around into the rest of the structure
and you've got your entire dome or
whatever round shape you're building oh
it's also kind of funny is I ended up
going with these adventure temple pieces
to make the little pillars let's hope of
the spire because I couldn't find any
better pieces for that
and honestly this just works out really
well I'm pretty happy with how this
looks it's like these pieces were made
for it
friendly reminder that any moving piece
in planet coaster you can use a trigger
or you can you can turn on that it gets
turned on my triggers that make sense
and basically make it stop moving so if
you've got any kind of gear piece or
something like that
that you want to use because you think
it looks good but it doesn't fit your
build because it's an animated piece you
can always stop the animated or you can
stop the animation by clicking that
little box in the top right I believe it
is so yeah that's always quite handy and
definitely allows you to get more use
out of some of the animated pieces in
the game which is well animated as they
might be sometimes you just want to have
a still piece so moving on from there
the big gazebo like structure is
basically finished at this point but in
addition to that I wanted to cover the
exits which is a bit weird usually
you'll have a covered cue and just a
small open exit that leads you to the
path as soon as possible really the only
reason that I decided to make this exit
be covered and not allow people to get
onto the main path right away is because
I thought it looks better it adds some
extra architectural elements to the
street and kind of makes this path a bit
of a canyon between the flat ride cover
and the restaurants which I built in the
last episode and I think it also looks a
bit better from the cue because I'm
trying to make the cue its own little
themed area going over that pond with a
wooden bridge and having a view of the
restaurant as well as the flat ride and
of course an important sight line with
seeing the mountain with the church on
top in the distance behind it I really
wanted to make the cute part of the
scenery and this building just felt like
it fits in here and felt like a good
addition to the park in that sense so
yeah I'm really going for design over
function here but I mean in the end the
design of the theme park is kind of the
function as well you know you're
supposed to make
you'll feel like then a theme land and
appreciate the scenery so in that sense
I don't know I'm allowing this for
myself okay and yeah that's basically
the building itself finished and for the
rest of this episode I'm just gonna try
and put all kinds of scenery around it
to make it fit a bit more in the
surrounding area something that I think
is also worth pointing out is I've done
quite a bit of off-camera stuff as well
and I say quite a bit but I mostly spent
a lot of time rotating my camera and not
actually placing anything I know a lot
of other people are guilty of doing this
as well but I definitely spend half of
my time in planet coaster just moving
around the park and moving the camera
around and not doing anything but this
time it was actually kind of productive
because every few minutes or so or even
less often I was placing mountain trees
just because I felt that the park in
general didn't have enough trees and I
wanted to be a bit more foresty while at
the same time keeping all of the
important sight lines intact so this
process was really one of placing down a
tree and then looking at it from every
single angle to see if it breaks any
sight lines and if it looks good and if
it's okay moving on to the next three
etc which can be a super time-consuming
thing to do but to me it just adds so
much foliage is really important to make
things look good on one hand but on the
other hand you also don't want to the
foliage to block the views of the things
that you've built so trying to find a
balance between that I think is
something that you should be able to
spend quite a bit of time on if you want
to try and perfect the foliage in the
park because yeah it can be very time
consuming but it's also quite rewarding
and it can really make your buildings
look much better and make the park come
together anyway moving back to what I'm
actually building here this wooden
bridge is also very pointless you know
you could have easily just walked around
the pond but I'm going back Grylls on
this you know how Bear Grylls whenever
he finds a lake he has to cross it in
the most obscenely ridiculous way
possible he's just trying to show off
survival skills and in this case I'm
just trying to show off the scenery so
we are walking over
little pond just because it looks better
okay I think there is nothing
particularly wrong with that it's
something that actually in real life a
lot of gardens will do it's just part of
the landscape and it's also part of
trying to create a bit of a miniature
alpine landscape a very small scale in
this Q line to make for kind of a mini
natural area kind of like a Japanese
garden does sometimes I really like that
idea of emulating larger natural
structures like mountains and forests
and lakes on a very small scale in
gardens because I don't know that's
really what makes Gardens what they are
and what makes them so cool that you can
enjoy a natural landscape but on a very
small scale and yeah that is basically
all there is to it I'm just adding these
lanterns and adding some custom fences
here and there to give it a bit of a
more personal Flair than the the q lines
in game would have with their standard
railings but aside from that there
really isn't too much to it and I'm not
symbolically placing down any rocks to
represent mountains or any bushes to
represent forests directly in a way that
Japanese gardens would do for instance
I'm mostly just imitating these Alpine
landscapes with a lot of rocks scattered
about and flowers between them as you
might see in very high altitudes in the
mountains which is absolutely gorgeous
like honestly when you there are
sometimes these areas on mountains where
there's just rocks scattered about
everywhere and all of these rare flowers
that you only find at these Heights
everywhere it's super cool it's
something I could barely even try to
emulate in planet coaster but it's the
kind of feeling that I'm sort of going
for with this area in the Q line oh yeah
I'm pretty happy with it especially the
ground shrubbery is quite good although
in hindsight I really moved the park
border really close to this garden
something which I'm trying to do with
Jaeger horn to make it feel like it
could be part of a real life theme park
is established very hard and straight
borders on the outskirts of the park
which I don't know it's kind of a
limitation
that I'm giving myself because it forces
you to be more creative with how you
approach the edge of the park but it's
also in an attempt to make it seem as
though it could be part of a real park
because where those borders are would be
in real life where another themed area
would be or where some backstage areas
would be I definitely want to get into
some kind of next stage areas for this
park so I think it's quite important to
nail that Disney feeling but at times I
also feel like I put the borders maybe a
bit too close to the park like it's
really difficult to make things look
good if you really have to obviously
place a very very vertical tree line to
block the line of sights to what would
otherwise be backstage areas or empty
grassy planes but you know that's that's
part of the challenge and it's
interesting to try and make forests look
as diverse and dense as possible when in
reality it's just a single tree line
that's meant to make you not see what's
behind it it's something that in real
life I'm also always really fascinated
by in theme parks but yeah that is
basically it for this episode so I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
I'll leave you with some cinematic
overviews of this ride and just as a
reminder if you wanna donate to stick
thing up kicker and if you want to
support Joey and it's stupid ridiculous
quests to ride Condor for 20 hours in a
row you can find the links to that in
the description as well anyway thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next episode which will hopefully be a
bit sooner than usually because it's
going to be summer vacation from now on
so I'll have some more time yay
[Music]
[Music]
you